johnny coltrane up on the casino
exclusive
man ready set radio bootleg cab live in
studio we have got asher raw
first things first mr asher uh i'm a
arizona cardinals fan i know you're a
niners fan this is true i would like to
congratulate you on thank you man it's
been a long time coming i'm a niner
hater but you know what at least
somebody from the nfc west is like
really good yeah and at least kurt
warner is not wearing gloves anymore
i was a low blow
oh man
but uh yeah man hey you got the pabst
and jazz record that just came out man
and i've been sitting with the last
couple days since it dropped in
we've been playing we do an underground
hip-hop show we've been playing um
common knowledge and in the kitchen and
uh the paps and jazz and the joint with
action bronson choices yeah um
great dude front to back man thank you
man nobody will work that's what we're
trying to do is just put out quality
product i mean uh it's been interesting
to really kind of go through the ride do
the isle of college stuff and then put
out grind okay right it's a new day and
you know not really see that get the
same reception that i love college did
and then do you know have the greenhouse
effect and do seared foie gras with
quince and cranberry and that's what
yeah exactly uh so this one it's cool to
see kind of it all be coma it's all it's
all coming together which is basically
all right there's good rhymes there's
good beats and it's all come down to one
and it got a little love so yeah shout
out to the blended babies
shout out jp rich gaines shout out to
chicago really holding me down on that
they produced a record there was like a
group
pulled over by the cops or something was
that freddy kids the cool kids yo
they're gonna be so happy when they hear
that yeah man pulled over that record we
played that record that record was crazy
crazy man yeah they're absolute animals
i'm really excited for the blended
babies they're going to be doing some
really really big stuff in 2012. most
definitely now um there has been quite
the resurgence of uh
new white rappers this year yeah
a lot of new white guys are rapping man
um i feel like uh
you were kind of like
i was i've been a fan since the
greenhouse effect like back when i was
working in phoenix that was one of my
favorite mixtapes um
and i thought man i really thought that
you were like the next guy to blow on
some like superstar-ish and i really was
uh i was kind of disappointed with how
people received the debut album you know
i think they kind of boxed you in
um as a college right you know
with
situation you're finally going to get
the look that you deserve as as an emcee
yeah i mean the labels are labels uh and
it's really it's amazing for me to be
part of one loud and steve rivkin and
yeah def jam so from a historical
standpoint it's like all right word you
know what i'm saying it's great but most
like storied really i mean loud and deaf
so that's cool from that standpoint and
just to have people excited it's fresh
now over at def jam it's it's it's uh
it's it's new for everybody involved so
that's in my favor uh but at the end of
the day man it really comes down to me
and that's something that i've learned
is where when i first came out the gate
and we had this huge record it was just
like a lot of people were just oh we'll
do it all for you right and i'm young so
i'm just like okay i trust you guys uh
and then you know i've taken a few steps
back and just thought about what do i
want to do where do i want to take this
thing and uh and that's why i'm excited
about the depth jam thing is because now
we have a historical label um especially
in the hip-hop world and
which is excited about me and now i have
a clear-cut vision on where i want to
take my music so i hope i just hope that
my fans are ready to be challenged my
listeners are ready to be challenged i'm
going to continue to challenge myself
obviously paps and jazz is new it sounds
new
and that's the kind of stuff that we're
trying to do is just continue to
progress and progression is kind of key
so uh yeah i mean with all the white
rappers and other things that's going on
that's cool i mean there's so many now i
almost just look at it as rappers it's
yeah now it's just rappers i think it's
an action bro i think when you when you
started to pop like it was kind of like
oh there's a new white rapper and then
now it's just kind of like
it's dope because it's just everyone's
just looked at as mc's so we'll see man
i mean that's it i'm just trying to
differentiate myself from the from the
pack and just be dope and
and do cool stuff man and that's it most
definitely um i also wanted to ask you i
know that you and you you've known
justin bieber for a minute i was talking
to scooter when he was up here he said
there might be a justin bieber record on
your album
well possibly
with someone whose name might rhyme with
schmish mound you know it's it's a uh
it's an asher roth record but justin
bieber is on the record he's on that
yeah man it's it's dope i mean we've uh
justin and i have kind of uh you know
grown up together for lack of better
words he was down in atlanta with me and
uh we took care of him for a little bit
and watched it you were like the
babysitter to the superstar that he is
yeah man but it's funny enough he's
taught me he's taught me so much man he
taught me to just go get it you know
what i mean that kid doesn't doubt
himself for five seconds he does it all
one thing i see him like kicking soccer
balls with barcelona and next thing he's
like scoring goals and toronto maple
leafs jerseys and now and he has hit
records too so uh he taught me a lot
about just like going and getting it and
just seeing a young kid be so uh so
passionate about what he's doing is
pretty dope so i mean we got up we uh i
mean i wrote a record and they responded
to it and and chris and justin kind of
had a little competition uh about who
could who could write a cooler verse for
it and they turned out pretty good so
we'll see man no names yet but there's
definitely some exciting and different
features on and and more to come so uh
yeah we're just trying to give people a
lot of options is this gonna be a record
that bieber and chris brown are rapping
on or singing we'll see man we'll see
okay we'll find out that's what it is is
the album still called is this too
orange yes this too orange man it comes
out in march i wouldn't be surprised if
it gets pushed back because that's just
like one of those things but now we're
shooting from march i really think it's
going to come out in march uh early
march at that we're going to try to
really attack march madness i'm a big
college basketball and uh we're gonna
we're gonna really try to attack uh
spring break as well what is uh what is
the the story behind the title man uh is
this too orange kind of just hit me man
but it's it's really about uh colors and
music in respects to uh you know pops
and jazz feels very purple and blue you
know and then you have is this too
orange which feels it's warmer it's it's
red it's yellow um and and i think
that's what's really fun for me is to uh
kind of do different stuff and and use
multiple outlets using releasing music
on twitter and releasing music on
facebook and then also having music on
the radio and if we can cover a lot of
ground like that where we're you know
all over the internet and all over uh
the mass m right we're in good shape so
uh yeah we're just using our using uh
our our tools wisely and uh and that's
really it so is this too orange kind of
just hit me half asleep and oren yoel
shout out to oran diddle who did a lot
of the the production on um on asleep in
the breto uh he and i have really kind
of grown up together and and progressed
together as well so i'm excited for
everybody here his new work oh and and
building off of the foundation that we
created with really the greenhouse
effect you know beautiful hey i also
would like to thank you for being the
only rapper i know that ever has ever
referenced blumpkins in a rap
nice man i was just i was just pretty
geeked out about uh the magnus for
magnuson one recently i love i love uh
larkin in my go-karts but but we always
at my old station we always had like an
inside joke about getting blunted
and when that came out you said ash rock
the king of the blumpkin oh man that was
our joint
for all of y'all don't know
do not know what a blumkin is
urbandictionary.com
urbandiction yeah urbandictionary.com
yes most definitely um another thing i
wanted to ask you man
as far as you know you you to me you're
one of the nicest on the mic um
but i think you're you're really
underrated do you feel like you're
underrated as a rapper man it's all
subjective dude i've got people who are
like oh you're overrated
so it's really kind of uh subjective i
know that uh we've put a lot of work in
i know that it's obvious that we've
inspired some of the young kids and
that's all that matters to me is that we
are contributing yeah you know what i'm
saying so as long as we're contributing
and it's not just take take take take
we're actually giving back and doing
some cool stuff and and giving uh giving
the kids something that they can relate
to that's important to me because
obviously hip hop has changed
drastically since i was young um you
know and and the kind of whole that was
turned into this whole kind of get rich
quick scheme and stuff we've been
dealing with for the past 10 years uh
very devoted to uh to radio and stuff
like that and almost completely changing
genre it's nice to just get back to
music with a message and uh as long as
we can do that and people recognize that
that's all that's important man but
definitely get ready it's a new day that
we will play that here man that was a
great song is that is that gonna i mean
it sounds like uh over a year old now is
that gonna be on the album
it needs to be reborn man it's like a
great record such a great record we have
a we have a special guest on the remix
of it so uh but yeah i think i think
that one will pop back up man but we
perform that one people go nuts so it's
really man that was a really interesting
thing for me to put that record out
because when i put it out i was like man
i love this [__] i thought that was i
was like this is good
you know what to be honest with you man
that really showed me uh the power of
labels and that's why i'm still willing
to cooperate with major labels because
if you can use their resources and
they're excited about you you can do
some really powerful things but we had
not sold
uh the record company on that record
they're like hey this is a great record
let's put it out but it didn't get that
push so it kind of hit a glass ceiling
to just my main audience so you know it
got a thousand uh like a million views
on on vivo or whatever and that was it
right so uh it kind of hit that glass
ceiling and but it's it was cool to see
i mean we performed it in chicago and i
saw the video i just pretty much held
the mic out and kids know all the words
so and it's got one of those legendary
openings where you just play it and
somebody knows what it is so uh yeah man
that's it just trying to make good music
that's really all it comes down to no no
algorithms that's what's up man how did
you choose what mc's to work with on
patch and just i know you had casey
veggies on there blue yeah which is like
kind of a diverse yeah no and i mean all
those dudes it's just uh that was one
thing that was super important about
pabst and jazz is the communal aspect of
it and uh bringing in a lot of people
from different walks of life right and
kind of different generations of rhymers
as well and that's just it's just uh one
jp obviously i worked very very closely
because of the blended babies in chicago
yeah uh you know it's a hub there
chicago is a hub and like rocky fresh
all those people they're like
kids these days uh and it's just a group
of like-minded individuals man every
time we we link up with these guys 12
you from the asap mob and
all these kids when we get in the same
room when we talk and we chop it up
we're all on the same page we're just
like man we just want to do some
something cool we just want to have this
one i just want this to be dope i don't
even want to worry about this other
stuff so
uh you know bronson gets on a record and
that's just because we both like you
know big wrestling fans and all that and
then some and i was spending a lot of
time in new york and i think when when
bronson jumped on the track and being
how in new york hip-hop right now action
is probably one of my favorite rappers
yeah no he's dope he's standpoint he's
just
the static selected well done album is
crazy see you know man the doctor
elector's crazy he's got a million more
projects coming out too and i'm just
like thrilled for him because he's dope
and he just doesn't take himself too
seriously you know which is great which
i think it's a super important question
in an mc yeah it's a very important
quality uh so when that happened i think
a lot of people understood what we were
trying to do uh and and it it just it
just spawned like hey let's we really we
recorded that we recorded that all those
sessions in three days in la because i
didn't have a car so i was just stranded
jp came over we did about 17 songs oh
wow which is crazy that doesn't normally
happen that's not normally the output
but i was kind of uh kind of depressed
so so to speak and then uh
and then you know we got all these
features again like probably six days
before the tape even dropped where
people are just like i want to be on
this record i want to be on this right
we just started handing it out and it
was it was just special man the whole
way the whole
thing came together was just very
natural very organic and it's just like
supposed to happen in the kitchen that's
one of my favorite songs of the year man
that that's what's up yeah
chuck another one of those dudes that's
uh that's family of me man that's one of
those guys who i support uh regardless
and he's doing some really cool stuff
there's a b tape coming out top of the
year called working uh he's got some
other stuff he's uh working on a sounds
like fun project uh and yeah chuck chuck
can't do any wrong in my eyes man he
does it for the right reasons with the
right people he uh he played that beat
for me like he came over he was working
on the beat with the headphones took the
headphones off played it and i was just
like wow that joint came together in
about half an hour common knowledge came
together in about half an hour and you
can tell man cause there's no disconnect
between vibes no it's listen
yeah it's a cohesive project for sure so
we're excited about it man so if you if
you guys haven't got it yet check out
paps and jazz trending worldwide on
twitter it was man we got a trending
worldwide on twitter it was really cool
to see and that's that's it we're
working really hard organically right
now and uh just getting back to the
things that really matter and obviously
look out for the def jam release is this
too orange and there's going to be
continual projects a lot of videos a lot
of fun to be had